I keep falling asleep on everything I
saw American fiction amazing movie for
the first half of what I saw and I just
fell tap to yeah wow did you see salurn
oh I saw that one really oh crazy I got
some heat for you bro Bollywood heat no
I mean some to get back at him cuz it's
white boy [__] mud in that [__] and
he's going to town yeah he's going to
town what is this movie send me time
stamps white send me time stamps did you
get to the end of it you get to the end
son he is [__] [__] out of this mud
bro what is it about it's too gay like
he's going in it is gay there's gayus
there's gayus but lowkey I like it cuz
it's gayous but it's like it's Sinister
it's gayous but it's heinous you know
what I'm saying bro it's a cool movie
it's gay you it's gay but it's Al like
the gay salurn the gay guys may be a bad
guy no no it's actually it's actually
really I'm not watching that [__] son he
why you want me to watch gay [__] son
it's not gay gay can you try to find it
just cuz I'm telling you Akash is
Vindicated now y
disgusting animals you guys are animals
yeah I don't know about the uh I don't
know about this K
movie
right it's really good actually no are
you gonna be bothered because their gay
performance is better than yours yeah
they're better gay actors yeah but they
took those roles when they didn't have
to okay that's gay fair fair fair fair
fair oh bro what's going on over there
I'm pulling it up it's I can't find it
exactly but there's oh [__]
okay oh my God yo this is
crazy son this is
crazy don't do yo he goes to work bro
that's Barry kogan or
whatever don't make it about the actor
yo y [__]
about now he came to the uh seller he
came for sure
yo y'all some mud [__] ass white
folks he wanted to be under the ground
he went to the seller he was trying to
we do it you know for
acting it's not real don't believe
everything you see performance don't
believe everything you see performance
art He Did It For Love let the record
you you good Hindu you a good Hindu I
love youo I don't believe he did it bro
oh my God you see this this is graphic I
even see it son they don't got no
prosthetic on that thing at all oh his
dick is out son he's going [__] the
ground like you see he also is a method
actor I know oh he's a method actor so
he really did he's definitely naked
[__] mud on the side that mud
dude I don't get what you're telling me
Al or not he's fully naked and he's
fully penetrating that okay come on bro
is it like a bog oh son it's a grave
it's a grave y'all are [__]
disgusting that's not mud yesterday it
was raining M it's mud it was R mud yeah
yeah it was raining he's [__] the mud
to [__]
corpse y weird yo is it a
bog does it have some why you know so
much about mud you white [__] I'm
Scottish we got bogs bro you know what I
mean it might be some water underneath
and it's easier to [__] through but just
[__] through Straight like six feet
of watch I can't wait somebody push that
I can't find it you got to watch please
send us that c please send us that clip
yo I don't think my been on this whole
time
please it's
on no I I can't find you can get some
pcks though this [__] is is is insane he
takes his whole pants off he get butt
ass and starts going to [__] [__]
weirdos y'all are weirdos y'all are
disgusting this is about love though you
got understand it's not about the it's
not about the mud it's about what the
mud represents oh man which that's
actually the gayest thing I've ever said
bro I don't think he [__] it yo son oh
my God you got to watch
this is good family viewing but you
don't see his meat where the top you do
you see his
meat stop pretending y don't [__] mud
this been your big secet that's why you
been putting it on me you've been
projecting that's why your population is
low y'all be [__] mud instead of
people I don't know I'll be honest with
you I don't know billion pick it up from
we probably picked it up from y that's
cute when we were Daddy when we were
daddy oh you got to go with that huh I'm
just telling you I'm just telling you
why can we oh we get religion for you
but we can't get [__] from you
that's convenient chicken Tika but not
[__] you bit something saying
it seems to me that as a British dude he
probably learned that when we why that a
British dude Barry kyogi is from Ireland
oh that's a British dude oh I don't know
if he's from North Ireland Orel you
British dude I'm British yeah have you
seen the flag St Andrew's flag is the
British flag [__] dude have you not seen
the flag yeah I still don't have freedom
English flag it's our look say again
English flag no no British Great Britain
the English flag is the
cross the x is the one that everybody
knows this is obviously a Scottish flag
is incorporated oh yeah take your flag
huh no we bullied their flag okay and
just completely dominated the bloodline
until they let the Germans in no big
deal is what it is um y'all [__] mud
dude y'all [__] Indians fire fire yo
that's sh Toom y that's
gross that's so much gross you still on
V y'all did it the two billion times H
this is as close as I can get oh he's
close with the nukes godam come on
dude yeah he he gets all up on it takes
okay this [__] is broken internet's
broken yo you really suck the internet
is broken I do let me
just this a rough episode for you mark
this has been a real bad episode for you
mark first one of the Year all right yo
yo let's yo put a put $10 now pricee
pick is going to multiply the [__] out
of it if you get off that's right to
match your initial deposit up to 100
bucks okay simple as that you go to
prize pick you use the code
Schultz prize.com use the code Schultz
SZ they're going to match your initial
deposit up to $100 you put in 100 they
put in 100 you take the oash sing locks
and you generate some real Revenue we
know it's the first of the new year you
spent all your money on Christmas
presents spent all your money on a crazy
New Year party time to get a little bit
more in your pockets and let prize picks
do it for you